today I'm going to tell you about how
other people can make us healthier and
we're perhaps used to the idea that
other people can make us mentally
healthy they can improve our happiness
and make us more satisfied with life but
what you may be not so used to thinking
about is how other people can make us
physically healthier so how they can
help us stave off disease improve our
immune system and even help us live
longer and to do this i'm going to give
you an example so i'd like to introduce
you to my grandmother marion greenaway
Marion has some pretty significant
health problems she's legally blind she
has a hearing deficit and some pretty
serious heart problems but despite that
she's doing really well for her age she
just turned 91 earlier this year that
puts her 10 years over the average life
expectancy in Australia and she still
lives in independent living an
independent living retirement village
which means that she's still looking
after herself in a way similar to she
was 10 years ago or even 20 years ago
and I think that a big part of Marion's
health and vitality really comes from
her very rich social life so Marion
lives in a retirement village that very
much encourages social activities and
interactions among its members she's a
member of many local clubs and actually
founded several local clubs and every
afternoon at four she gets together with
a friend across the road and they have a
glass of wine and they read together and
i was told that her most recent reading
venture was the book 50 shades of grey
and she told me that it didn't teach her
anything that she didn't already know
which I personally didn't need to know
but in fact Marion social life is so
good that she once had to put off an
appointment with her eye specialist from
december to january because she had too
many christmas parties to attend and it
turns out that these sorts of social
interactions this rich social life is
one of the best things that you can do
for adding years to your life so this is
an image of someone's social network of
friends on facebook and the more
connections you have the richer your
social network the healthier people tend
to be and its effect of having more
social connections is actually
comparable to a number of medical
interventions that were typically used
to thinking about as making us healthier
so these are odds ratios for living
longer given a particular medical
intervention so if you're overweight or
obese and you reduce your BMI and you
increase your chances of living longer
by up to twenty percent you get a
similar boost for getting vaccinated and
also for reducing your amount of
drinking if you often drink alcohol to
excess the big one obviously is quitting
smoking if you give up smoking then you
increase your chances of living longer
by up to fifty percent and when we
compared with this the effect of having
more social connections in your life the
difference between having one person
that you can talk to about your problems
versus being socially isolated then we
increase our chances of living longer by
up to sixty percent so that's an effect
that's comparable to or even slightly
better than these traditional medical
interventions that we typically think of
as making us healthier and it's
statistics like this that have lead
political scientists Robert Putnam to
conclude that if you smoke and belong to
no groups then statistically it's a
toss-up whether you should stop smoking
or start joining and that's because
groups give us some really important
things that are very protective for our
health and well-being they give us a
sense of social connection with other
people in a sense of social identity
when we think about identity
often we think about the things that
make us unique or different from other
people but in fact a big part of our
identities is wrapped up in the things
that we have in common with other people
or the group memberships that we share
so a big part of my identity is the fact
that I'm a woman and an academic and an
Australian which might make it slightly
strange that I have a picture of the new
zealand all blacks football team behind
me but these kinds of group memberships
are very important and the degree to
which people identify with these groups
or adopt them into themselves as
important characteristics of who they
are and the degree to which they feel a
sense of social connection or oneness
with those groups has very profound
impacts on people's health so people who
identify with groups tend to be
healthier and i'm going to give you an
example of a few studies that have
demonstrated this point that joining
groups are identifying with groups can
make us healthier so in this first study
they were interested in the issue of
getting older adults to drink more water
because dehydration is a big problem
among many people in aged care
facilities and what these researchers
did was they had half of the
participants join a water club or a
group about water so they got together
they talked about water they drank water
together and for the other half of
participants they did the same thing
they thought about what are they drank
water but they did it alone and these
researchers were interested in the
number of doctors visits that these
participants had in the 12 weeks after
this intervention and it turned out that
people who joined the water group were
half as likely to go to the doctor in
that 12-week period as people who were
in the alone group or in the alone
condition and it's not just in terms of
physical health that groups can be
beneficial it's also in terms of our
cognitive health so in this next study
I'll tell you about the researchers
weren't interested in the effect of
joining groups versus not they were
interested in the effects of identifying
with healthier or less healthy groups so
in this study they did it in a really
clever way they had they recruited
people who were aged 60 to 70 and they
told half of the participants that they
were recruiting p
aged 50 to 60 so these participants felt
as though they're on the higher end of
the age spectrum in this study and they
were self-identifying as being older
individuals for the other half of
participants they told them they were
recruiting people aged 70 to 80 so they
were on the younger age of the end
spectrum age spectrum so these
participants actually self-identified as
being younger and then they gave
everyone a test that very accurately
diagnoses the onset of dementia and a
score of 82 or below on this test
indicates that you have symptoms of
dementia on average people who
identified as being old scored below
this critical cutoff point whereas
people who self-identified as being
young scored above it they were
protected against the effects of
presenting with dementia and it's even
more striking when you look at the
percentage of people in each condition
who presented with symptoms of dementia
so fourteen percent of people in the
young condition who felt young presented
with symptoms of dementia compared with
seventy percent of people who identified
as being older so simply the act of
identifying with a group that we
consider as having cognitive deficits
versus identifying with a group that we
think is relatively protected is enough
to change our scores on these very
accurate tests that diagnose dementia so
what these studies are telling us is
that group identification and joining
groups is very important and protective
for our health and well-being and the
question that we're asking now is why so
what is it about groups that gives
people this protective benefit and there
are a range of different processes that
go into this summer very biological or
physiological it has to do with the
boost that your immune system gets from
being with other people and having these
regular social connections other
processes are more social so it has to
do with when you join groups you have
access to social support and social
capital people that you can rely on to
help you achieve the things that you
want in life I'm a social psychologist
so I'm particularly interested in the
psychological benefits that group
memberships can
give us so how do groups actually change
the way that we think about ourselves
and the world and how does that feed
into our own mental and physical health
and it turns out the group's give us a
range of different psychological
benefits that can be protective for our
health and well-being they give us a
sense of meaning so we feel as though
the world is worthwhile and our purpose
here is worthwhile they can help our
self-definition so they give us more of
a sense of who we are and what we want
out of life and what I'm particularly
interested in is that groups can
actually give us a sense of perceived
control over our lives so they can make
us feel agenta canned capable of
achieving the things that we want out of
life they can turn us from being passive
passengers in the passenger seat of life
to active go Gators who go out and able
to achieve the things that they want and
it turns out that a sense of control is
incredibly important and protective for
your mental and physical health I think
this has been touched on a little bit
already today and it's something that
John will continue to touch on in his
keynote later on just to give you one
example of an experiment that has
demonstrated this some psychologists
went into an aged care home and for half
of the participants they really
emphasized a sense of high personal
control so they told these people if you
want anything changed in this facility
if if you're unhappy with something or
want something done differently then you
have that power you're able to go out
and do that it's up to you and for the
other half of participants they said
everything's under control generally if
there's anything you would like changed
or done differently than the nurses are
here to help you just tell them and
they'll take care of everything so in
both cases a positive message just one
emphasizes a high degree of personal
control and the other emphasizes a low
degree of personal control the
researchers went back one year later and
they found that participants who were
empowered with a sense of high personal
control were happier they were more
engaged but critically they were fifty
percent more likely to still be alive
so in this case having a sense of
control was actually the difference
between life and death and I'll point
out that this fifty percent is
comparable to the effect of giving up
smoking that we saw earlier just having
a sense of control over your life so the
model that we're working from now is the
idea that identifying with groups having
group memberships can give us a sense of
personal control over our lives and for
that reason is protective and beneficial
for our mental and physical health and
we've been looking at this in a range of
different groups mostly around people
who have experienced adverse life
circumstances so we've looked at it in
religious people who have experienced a
life trauma in Republicans who have
experienced the 2012 u.s. presidential
election loss we've looked at it in
students who are facing their most most
stressful final year of exams and we've
even looked at it in the most vulnerable
of populations recovering drug and
alcohol addicts and in all of these
groups we find the same thing which is
that identifying with an important group
in your life gives you a sense of
control over your life and that control
can protect your health and well-being
even in these very adverse life
circumstances so I'm going to leave you
with a final thought and that is that
the things that we typically think of as
making us healthy these kinds of typical
medical interventions that we think of
might have led us to overlook a resource
that we have under our noses which is
other people the social connections we
make in the social relationships that we
have and when my grandmother goes to her
doctor for her checkup it's likely that
she's asked questions about these kinds
of medical factors what's a diet like
has she been exercising lately has she
had any injuries or illnesses it's
unlikely that she's going to be asked
questions like has she talked to anyone
recently when was the last time she
spoke with her family and friends has
she joined any new groups lately
and these questions are actually
incredibly important for understanding
our health and well-being and it turns
out that the answers might hold the key
to living happier healthier and even
longer lives thanks
you